This is a comment on one of my videos
where I state that the healthcare is free in Sweden
and so are education.
However, obviously it's not free,
it's tax funded.
It's a socialistic system.
But growing up in Sweden,
socialistic country,
it is like it is free
because you don't know anything else.
You pay your taxes,
which is about 28 to 35%
depending on what county you live in.
And then you get free healthcare,
you get free education,
you have a society that takes care of you.
Which is like
the same amount of tax that I pay here in New York.
But the difference is that I don't get shit
from my tax money here in the US.
So while you are yelling that it's not free,
people are growing up in Scandinavia
socialistic countries
getting their bachelor's degree for free,
getting their master's degree for free.
Because we pay the same amount of taxes that you do.
But we are taxing the rich
so everyone has access to education and healthcare
cause we are smart people.